Oscar goes to
[Music]
things were looking up for rami malek
after winning Best Actor at the 2019
Oscars this is a monumental moment one
I'm so appreciative to all of you but
then things went south literally when he
fell off the stage right after accepting
his award
here's Rami after he took a tumble
hanging on to the side of the stage
people nearby rushed to help him up EMTs
were even called to the scene
thankfully the 37 year old actor was
seemingly cleared to celebrate et's
cameras captured Rami right after the
show at the Governor's Ball and he
seemed to be in great spirits ready to
party I don't like to pull the Freddie
moves out much but if there's ever a
night across town at the Vanity Fair
party et was with Allison Janney who
presented Rami with his Oscar during the
ceremony you were inside
did you see Rami Malek fall off the
stage he was treated by paramedics after
his win is what we saw in Twitter I'm
confused because I was right there with
him I was I saw him I gave him his award
and walked offstage with him and hugged
him and and he got off the stage
successfully with me so I don't know
what happened after he left my I have to
investigate that sighs I'm hearing of it
that's not I'm I'm like I need to go
find him right now and make sure he's
okay he's a national treasure I didn't I
didn't know that you're the he's okay
even they just said he was treated by
paramedics after felling the stages oh
it was mine when I left him it's not her
fault people I took really good care of
him you know I gave it I gave him his
Emmy and I gave him his Oscar that's a
bit of a bit of trivia I presented him
his
Semmy and his Oscar so I'm a good luck
charm for Rami and back at the
Governor's Ball the party continued
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]